so is it tougher to compete today than
or them because the way i see it is
uh it was a monopoly back then because
back then it had a lot to do with who
you knew like you had to kiss a lot of
ass to move up back then
today
it's so noisy to probably make it
today's gotta be
it's gotta be it's a different kind of a
heart i i guess the hard back then was
connection the heart today is
if you're not good
you ain't gonna last too long if you're
not good if you're good and you put in
the work eventually the market's gonna
you know picking you up yeah something's
gonna happen
but there's that cult of the amateur
right what i like about today actually
though with social media is that you've
got a lot of comics from all over the
world man you got a lot of brown comics
you got killers coming out of the middle
east killers coming out of india killers
coming out of pakistan my one of the
guys is going to open for me he's going
to do a guest spot it's from pakistan
killer and and that there is a whole
there is a whole artistic movement
coming out of that part of the world and
they don't have to speak they can speak
urdu they can speak hindu they don't
have to speak english and they have a
massive audience and they're crushing it
and then some of them are you know their
parents
went to england and they're coming in
and just taken over so it's competitive
bro you're competing with the world dude
big time but but growing up you said i
don't think you have to be and this is a
fact you don't have to be really good
anymore because they're still going to
come watch you because of the following
i mean that's why i was saying that it's
been tainted because they're not dude
off of what you said to get another one
of you or joe rogan or or one of these
big names
i i don't see unless they're gonna come
like diamond in the rough and because
they're just putting out a special
special his body uh uh uh
what's his name marcelo marcel hernandez
marcelo hernandez 20 what is he 23 24 oh
we saw him right yeah yeah he's got
funnies super
talented
talented and
witty i think he opens for uh tim dillon
oh great yeah you know patrick listen a
lot of times we might be talking like
old guys
you know let me tell you something when
you get to a certain age you get over 40
what you start doing inevitably is we go
you know these young guys they just
don't come up the way we did it
they're not grounded
and i think that's been a phenomenon
since i had a history teacher who read
the lament of an older man about these
kids who are materialistic don't know
the meaning of hard work it was a guy in
ancient rome talking about the youth of
and it was such an eye opener i went
yeah
dude i'm falling into this trap right so
i think to your point i'm glad you
brought it up is is
great artists people who are intelligent
who have an original way of looking at
things that hold your attention
they'll always be there and that's
what's that's what's beautiful about
stand up the idea is the idea is you
know how you opened it up when you said
everybody thinks they're special but you
know we're just regular people and then
i said to you there's some people that
think they're really special right so
this this thing right here is yours
right nobody else has got this this is
yours this maybe you can change it
nowadays to look like whoever you want
to look like sure you know advancement
is solid but this is you right so a kid
who's coming up was like dude you have
no idea how bad i want the world to know
what i'm special there's something
different about me and everybody else
did that energy if it's real
for that person and it's that important
the world is eventually somehow
somewhere gonna hear about who this guy
is or this gal is somehow some way the
next great one's around the corner we
have no clue who they are i just wonder
if the world you're because i'm
fascinated by khan my whole family
we grew up i was one of the biggest
pranksters in the army some of the
pranks i've pulled till today they talk
were you in the army i was in the army
man we were like not the pranks i pulled
eighty percent of them are inappropriate
i mean someone's gonna one day tell
these pranks that i didn't cancel things
at the highest level like if some of
this stuff was was just which is
terrible but back then it's just like
listen you're in the army you're doing
what you're doing because they did it to
you now you're doing it back to sure the
new guys that are coming i grew up in a
family middle eastern armenian assyrian
sarcasm jokes shots
if you couldn't handle being a bed david
or bohotian you changed your last name
to something else that david it was a
very rosie very moral yeah
i mean you couldn't it was a difficult
place to be and then and then that
continued in high school and then it
continued in the army where we had a
crew so guys were like hey can i go
party with you guys nashville i wouldn't
go to connections i want to go to a mix
factor i was going like dude i'm telling
you i don't think you can hang with us
right and then they would come in and
say i was oh my god you guys are
ruthless yeah that's kind of how just
that's where you grow up yeah i grew up
in l.a i grew up in glendale yeah i grew
up in glendale went to glendale high
school and then you know went to the
army and came back but you speaking
fluent i speak fluent
blue and assyria and the syrian farsi
that's crazy
yeah i speak uh i speak a few languages
i break out the old testament right now
so by the way you know the passion of
the christ when you watch them we
actually understand what they're saying
because we speak arabic
when we hired as a dialect coach she was
a female dead dude i i didn't have to
read that you know
because they're influenced yeah by the
way he speaks better than i do no no no
no no i tell people
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]